not all of ulnur's family made it out
he weeps for a cousin and a nephew
both killed in elginina
and he worries for those they left
behind
members of the ethnic African masalitha
Community he says they had to lie about
who they are
to avoid execution at the hands of the
janjaweed who arriving refugees and Aid
groups say are seemingly trying to
cleanse the capital of Sudan's West
Darfur region of rival tribes
the fight in al-janina is about
finishing off the Masala tribe they
destroyed all our neighborhoods there
they destroyed every place where masalid
are staying now this situation is
horrible every morning you wake up you
hear about someone having been killed
he Bears the marks of beatings he
endured at a checkpoint as his children
were forced to watch
even his pregnant wife due any day now
was not spared beatings
a lot of people from our family have
died we don't know who is left because
there is no network we can't speak to
each other
elginina is beginning to slowly empty
out slowly trickle out into Audrey there
are about two or three of these kinds of
impromptu makeshift camps around the
town and those lucky enough to make it
out of the besieged capital of westar4
are coming to places like this they are
setting up tents with plastic tarps with
bits of cloth with tree branches and
twigs and they are here exposed to the
elements waiting for any kind of help to
arrive
even in these conditions precious
moments of levity
offer a peek into the resilience of
people forced to endure what some are
beginning to describe as yet another
genocide in Darfur
but reality snaps back quickly
children the most vulnerable are
suffering most Fatima says her son was
perfectly healthy five months ago now
clearly in need of serious medical
attention he could not get in elginina
that he will not get in a refugee camp
so they must wait
and hope they say for the world to wake
up to a war within a war Zain Bas Ravi
al-jazeera Audrey Eastern Chad